hi guys I'm Greg
I'm Jerry we compete occasionally in the
movie trivia Schmo down so I talk with
Kristian harloff easy good he's he's
alright and we were talking about you
know he's like hey man what do you think
about doing like a little bit of a
reaction to a couple Schmo downs and I
was like you know what when I move into
the new place which I did and we don't
have a couch anymore because he couldn't
fit a couch to the hallways so we have
these temporary chairs right now new set
and everything Kickstarter we're gonna
get some better chairs yeah cuz we don't
want to pay for that ourselves well
we're back here we're gonna check out
from the movie trivia Schmo down
championship match
damn mural vs. John Roca Oh probably
only the first round or so that's not
the whole thing yeah play along I guess
when we do it we'll play along we'll
play along we'll get them all wrong
we're part of the young bucks
losers Hector Navarro aka Oscar Isaac
and it also features a cop sir aka one
of Shane's [ __ ] Esther and rv3 the
black guy at the Schmitt are the young
and us John and I'm sure they're so
happy to be a part of us really very
black consider the nice guys I like
being a nice young guy damn mural is the
movie trivia Schmo down champ and the
movie fights champion yeah he does a
great job
John Roca is the he's big competitor
Collider events he's been on movie
fights at John Roca is just like how he
is on camera he is loud and salting
degrading in-your-face cocky credibly
prideful narcissistic challenging and
overall just a very demeaning human
being and it really does get to your
skin yeah it's like I know he treats
everyone like this but when he talks to
me this way I feel it there's almost no
situation in which he won't burst into a
room and kind of you know his arms be
like what are you doing yeah well I can
try to you know coach you into doing it
right he'll like wave his belt in her
face and he's really intimidating and is
scary he told me I don't know how to
take shits yeah I was there for that it
was really weird I was trying to pee
right next to you and he just kept
waving the belt in my face
yeah square glasses zero none what did I
tell you from the beginning I want it
I want all the joy you don't can't take
their eyes on ya open their mouth start
with John Roca but this isn't just about
John Grogan this is about respect when I
[ __ ] John Campea they said I couldn't
feed him and I did when I fought Clark
wolf they said I couldn't feed her and I
did thank [ __ ] man
she gonna lose the man when I fought
Riley you lose - Riley unite fight Ella
she's gonna lose the else I'd be now saw
you didn't beat else by enough this
isn't about winning but sitting about a
championship isn't about beating John
Roca this is about respect
does sense yeah they're powdered if he
has respect I Thanks yeah it's kind of a
weird point least he was for me as like
earning the respect everyone else do
tell him I eat your death
I drink your haters tears yeah they
motivate me bring me fire it's all done
no you got once future
I am thus motown champion I don't want
to talk about the belt going back to
anywhere the belt stays with me mr. nice
guy and the champ is here he didn't drop
the mic
sound guys lose your [ __ ] title match
who now holds the bard men back what a
great first master ya Kalinowski and
McQueen with McQueen crushing it
TKO between is someone that could easily
face facing for a title sooner or later
whatever you're comfortable was saying
as far as an analogy standpoint maybe
they were the jalapeno poppers or the
guacamole did they were the appetizer to
the main dish Cristiano for Achilles the
baby back ribs are about to have that is
very very true my friend we are ready
for the main event and before we get to
the main event it falls on you guys if
you want to see more matches like this
if you want to see a potential big
matches like we keep teasing that rock
versus Kevin Hart match you want to see
all these big matches and wine matches
and stuff of that nature it's on you
click like comment keep doing that join
the movie trivia Facebook Throwdown page
make sure you do that and find out more
stats talk to your favorite competitors
all that stuff that's on you interact
one that do I'm here today ready for the
session wait to be a match and what a
champ is gonna get on the boards it is
the outlaw John Roca the number one
contender going up against dangerous Dan
Merle 5 a know the undefeated champion
who arguably is one of the best we've
seen at this game that's where you talk
about a question why not so often and it
really is gonna factor in here because
John Roca literally rode a horse to
today's event at the studio Dan Moreau
probably more of a Prius guy very
aggressive he gets excited about this
tomorrow
cool calm casual but he walks onto that
stage and he knocks it out of the park
he is still undefeated I believe he's
going for his sixth victory in a row
he's going for a sixth victory which
will be the most of all time he is the
fastest to ever get to five and oh he
has three knockouts he is the only
person to defend it twice he's going for
his third defense now he has been an
absolute madman in this league and we're
gonna see what he can do against Roco
who everything roca from the day I asked
him to be part of this he wants to be
the champion their roads are very
different
see how they came to be right now
Championship is on the line
friendship doesn't mean anything
coworkers don't mean anything or I don't
care if it's you I don't care if it's
Ellis or harloff or mance the
championships on the line I come to play
okay with me boy Bogdan and I was in no
offense but if I were you and I'd had
the title I have stayed the fighting
champion out of [ __ ] through the rounds
I don't but that's just me I mean that's
just me but I know you had to choose
what you attitude maybe you're exhausted
and tired from answering all the
questions once again wearing this belt
around it's pretty heavy so it's a hard
work you gotta rest up sometimes
champion you do your talking in the rink
which is where I plan to do it I like
being the champ
I like testing people I like coming
after me to be the champ and if I can be
the champ on more than one front I'm
happy to do it when we fight I want
every belt I want to I want to get in
shape and fight with WWE like everyone
else in the way that's the damn boy who
when you speak things into action into
the universe things happen if you commit
and focus and you fight when you're down
I've fought back and won and that's what
it takes one of them felt to run me now
but I have a shot for another rookies
got a great trivia mind personally am I
scared
no I mean he's got a lot of talk but I
don't see him with any of these listen
you and me you better worry about it
you're gonna hold on that belt when I
face you I don't think so I've been
working my ass off to fight damn row and
now the time has come I want all the
records I want all the belts I want all
the records oh god I can't believe we
compete in this row down I don't know I
don't know so you look at that story I
mean you get psyched up you know this is
the battle I mean roca almost had a shot
after this photo spectacular you took
that away from him as far as he's ever
been before which was a little awkward
in retrospect we were there so bad can
he take the one from Earl today I don't
know that anybody ever could but if
somebody wants it better than roca I
haven't met them yet the end the very
interesting part is that I saw a couple
of horsemen around - I didn't see much
of the Lions Den I know Dan has had some
issues with the way the Lions Den
handled that hole and Drako thing and I
haven't seen one of the Lions we'll
figure all that stuff out but I'm ready
to go here's the tale of the team
John Roca strengths yeah yeah biopics
never lost and running his mouth as
hopefully the Wow three minutes danger
enough Dan Morrill Spielberg movies
Oscar movies and smacking everyone
around in this leaf jackets but they're
not sitting in the back lip war theater
they're ready
movie trivia are Leos and gentlemen it's
time for the movies trivia now for the
undisputed championship of the world
first the Challenger
this is his moment can he deliver on the
moment maybe the thing we need to get
over the edge was having a group of
teammates true in the evening
it's a TV
that way
let's go no happy having for Roca all
right guys this is yeah this is the
championship we are ready to go I want
to say something yes all right there we
go of course you do
Danny Boy did you enjoy having the belt
for a little walk because it's time to
give it to me mark please tell him how
round one work gentlemen round one of
your championship match will be like
most red one who them questions from
around 1c categories each question
correct one point yeah they think they
have likes five rounds for these matches
what five holy [ __ ] Christian wants us
to watch for having directed you guys to
the rest of animated best category a
character named Lucy Wilde uses a
lipstick taser tickle which film
franchise your very good job yes we're
not playing a long time we don't know we
are but Chicken Little Miss World I do
something
and that makes me action adventures
Jason Statham plays Frank Martin what
film series isn't that the Italian job
no he's handsome you know your space
book you have the full rank Martin
Franklin is serious not definitely this
is one run a team so we can talk this
out for my event be Chelios and what
else is here with the sinking I got one
five four three two one
damn Louis incorrect John Las Vegas
incorrect looking for Reno Nevada
Danny was enough bang but prompted
Admiral promoting my shows at the st.
Louis funny bone Robert oh yeah [ __ ] out
that your family four to one
John correct correct
there we go taut tight tight game so far
all right category family films name the
bean John mouth like we we were talking
about
all right two days ago a couple weeks oh
yeah
Mike Jones correct Spike Jones alright
this is a championship match
no questions left in round one
your next category is fantasy science
fiction you'll find the Hornburg
franchise the Hornburg incorrect that
would be there was one without Kate
Beckinsale soon thereafter
like the one that just came out and does
it part four four three five five
correct as a team mark it's time for
round number two round we agreed to stop
at this point now go to the channel to
watch the rest of this match rest next
week in the description [ __ ] box
right down there see you were way better
as a team yeah I would never want to be
stupid we can talk things out like those
are times where we literally talk where
you're like you say something I'll get
it all say something you get so low I'm
like I get nervous as [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah I think you're the only person I
can like I can faithfully confer with
without any self-consciousness about
like you know cuz your mind will do
weird things when you're not entirely
comfortable yeah you're the one guy can
give it a dumb idea too and maybe we'll
get somebody like I would have killed
myself on the transporter question
because I was I've seen all the
transporter yeah wait a minute I know
that name and I'm like trying to think I
know it's not Craig is cheb Chelios yeah
easily but you had some wrong italian
job so yeah it's like they said that's
like a question that I got wrong I would
have hated myself every match has a
question that we've competed on where if
I get it wrong I hate myself
yeah I know that hey I'm thinking myself
right now like that was like I thought I
saw that in an article but I might have
been able to like process it boom yeah
than that because there's only one
without her right yeah there's only one
without her and two more after we gotta
get it guy get to the bottom of that all
right guys you can go over to Collider
videos watch this Schmo down match link
in the description box will let you know
when we'll be back on there meantime
check out our Collider nightmares video
it's a sketch we filmed that is based on
after we lost our first match towards
the etc' yeah that was a day that was a
day know also give some love to Collider
nightmares oh yeah guys watch Collider
night watch Collider nightmares one of
the few horror segments on and on
the channels yeah like an active channel
that goes consistently puts out horror
content weekly support that's gonna go
check him out at Clark Wolfe is amazing
she's [ __ ] beautiful and she's so
smart and she's terrific
I asked her out she said no laughed and
then she saw it was sad she's like oh I
didn't realize you're being serious I'm
like oh well now you realize I'm serious
are you gonna say yes and she's like no
sorry I'm sleeping with Mark Riley right
now and I'm like there's a mark have a
girlfriend of her fiance or wife or
something there's someone he's really
dedicated yeah and she's like yeah it's
a secret and I'm also sleeping with
Christian I'm like Christian has kids
and has a family this is really wrong
but I really loved and I had sex mark
you subscribe to the real rejects better
for no reason and Jon Niese added Jerry
and social media manager blue mouse and
rearrange X you can cut